in the beginning there was the eurozone
members and would-be members were
expected to limit their government
deficits to 3 percent of gross domestic
product and public debt levels to 60
percent this was meant to confine crises
to the past and guarantee stability so
far so good
but in 2008 a crisis broke out many
member states came clean about not
having followed the rules after all the
crisis had many causes but it didn't
help that all the countries have been
doing their own bookkeeping and
budgeting in isolation so in 2010 when
European defined its new strategy for
growth the objectives included better
coordination of national policies in the
areas of budget growth and employment
the member states and EU institutions
now work closely together to a precise
timetable during the preparations of
national budgets this process known as
the European semester allows the EU to
keep a close eye on the countries all
these institutions have their say on the
subject
first the European Commission sets the
priorities of the EU for the year ahead
the European Parliament and the EU
Council then discuss and approved them
at the beginning of every year each
member state is scrutinized on their
economic situation they reform programs
and potential imbalances the Parliament
can invite the presidents of other
institutions to discuss issues related
to the European semester and call for
dialogue with member states at the
Spring Meeting of the European Council
the heads of state and government set
the economic and fiscal guidelines for
the EU it sent up to Member States to
follow these in their reform agenda and
their plan to guarantee sound public
finances the EU institutions and review
the economic situation and policies of
each state and issue country specific
recommendations these recommendations
then have to be followed by Member
States when drawing up their national
budgets